communication with the pacific island
nation of tonga remains limited since
saturday's volcanic eruption and the
tsunami that came after it it's believed
the underwater cable that connects the
archipelago to the rest of the world was
severed during the disasters there is
still no official confirmation of
injuries deaths or serious damage in
tonga but that assessment is based on
limited information outlying coastal
areas they have been completely cut off
a prelude to a violent eruption
on friday the hunga tonga hunga hapai
volcano sent plumes of smoke and ash
shooting into the sky
activity that soon decreased
it would prove to be a brief respite
the next day
the volcano rumbled to life again
in an explosion so powerful it sent
shockwaves around the world
before and after satellite images
show how the volcano sea level crater
had disappeared following the blast
with regular communication lines to
tonga cut off
the world's been relying on satellite
phones and images to get a sense of the
disaster
we are still waiting to receive
uh information from tonga of what is
much needed but we know for sure that
there'll be uh
need for clean water because of the air
eruptions and
which really
imagine causing lots of uh
troubles to the water supplies in tonga
as most of the people collect water
through rain and this is something very
dangerous for them to consume
australia and new zealand have sent
surveillance flights to help assess the
scale of the damage especially on
tonga's outer islands where there are
fears the devastation could be immense
for more now i'm joined by professor
bettina choi she's a volcanologist at
the ludwig maximilians university in
munich professor it's good to have you
on the program i understand you have
actually studied and done research on
the volcano that erupted
there on tonga so explain to us
should we have expected an eruption with
this much power
well
in a way we could have expected that but
we know from the records that actually
every thousand years the volcano is
capable of producing such an eruption
the the enorm explosivity actually
is very hard to forecast here it came
from the very efficient mixing of the
hot magma with the the cold water which
made it that enormous
and when you see the images that you
know we're seeing right now
of all the just these clouds of ash
going up into the air
what does that tell you about
the situation on the ground on the
island
it's a very good question it's something
we all the entire community wonders
about
it's very hard to grasp and we're all
waiting for for getting insights from
the surveillance flights
um
we know that
the tsunami is triggered by the eruption
hit tonga we know that it hits the
other surrounding islands we don't know
yet
the the full width of the disaster we
know that there was ash fall we have
cell phone records of some
small pebbles along with that but we
don't know the quantities so that is can
be very threatening
and we we're still waiting to to hear
for for details on that and and do we
know how prepared is tonga for
this kind this caliber of a natural
disaster
for this caliber i reckon they're not
too well prepared but on the other hand
it's very hard to prepare for such an
extreme event
we have as i mentioned we have found in
the record that that happens every
thousand years so
the last one happened in
1100
so
to prepare for these extreme events
makes it very difficult
for
a tsunami in itself they might have been
prepared but now it's coupled with ash
with
more than one type
and also i mean
where tonga is in the world you know
around that pacific area this this ring
of fire i mean this is where we expect
to see this type of unsettled
movement and behavior if you will
of underneath the earth's surface right
yes so that the region is a very active
one it's the tongan kermadec arc where
the pacific plate is subducting beneath
the in the pacific one we have about
every 100 kilometers in the on the
seafloor we have a massive volcano
the
wood was seen on the ground uh these
little islands but just
the top of a giant volcano which now
erupted
so we know that this region is very
active it's part of the pacific ring of
fire so we can expect this however
just rarely in this extreme violence
yeah
professor bettina shaw joining us
tonight from munich professor we
appreciate your time and your valuable
insights thank you
thank you